[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
albert breer senior nfl reporter lead
content strategist for the monday
morning quarterback joining us on the
program before we get to antonio brown
more interesting quarterbacking
situation cleveland
pittsburgh
i think cleveland because cleveland to
me is more indicative of where like the
quarterbacking dynamic is going across
the nfl right now pittsburgh's i i think
sort of where like new england was
coming out of 2019
um where denver was coming out of 2015
where it's you had a quarterback who's
been there forever who's won super bowls
and
now you got to replace him and we've
seen that happen over and over and over
again over the history of the nfl
what cleveland's facing i think is a
little bit like
it's not exact but it's a little bit
like what we've talked about before damn
with the rams and the niners where
like you're happy with your quarterback
you can win with your quarterback you've
shown that you can get to the playoffs
with your quarterback but is that enough
and
i think it's sort of the
the mahomesization of the nfl where
teams are looking at these
opponents that have patrick mahomes or
josh allen
and the climb up that mountain is steep
and so it's not are you asking are we
okay with baker mayfield i think the
browns are okay with baker mayfield it's
more how much better do we need to be
than baker mayfield at quarterback
to get ourselves in a position to
contend for championships and so i think
very much that way you look at where the
browns are and it's not that baker
mayfield isn't a functional nfl
quarterback
it's how are we going to compete for the
next 10 years
with patrick mahomes in the afc with
lamar jackson in the afc with josh allen
in the afc with justin herbert and joe
burrow in the afc
and is baker mayfield good enough to get
us there
and i think because of the way he's
played this year they're going to be
exploring outside options to answer that
question well i think you you reported
this that cleveland could be in the
market for deshaun watson
and what did i i'm wondering this though
because maybe the browns are going to
have to face this dilemma
do we pay him 18 million dollars which i
think baker's owed this next year
and get through that season and run the
risk of he might play into a contract
extension or do we just rip the band-aid
off and say
we're in the market for another
quarterback here even though we could
get maybe a bargain at 18 million
dollars with baker well one nuance one
nuance that i think we have to remember
with um with that is that the the fifth
year options get fully guaranteed now in
the past it wasn't in the past you were
able to cut the cut your first round
pick from four years earlier if you got
to the end of the four fourth year and
you'd exercise the option now you you
don't have the same flexibility to do it
so like but i do think like the the
browns could probably find a trade
partner uh for baker mayfield like let's
say sean payton's still in new orleans
next year
uh then you know i think they would be
looking at options at quarterback and
they loved sean loved baker mayfield
coming out in 2000
um in 2018 so like would there be a home
like that for baker mayfield so i do
think there'll be some options out there
for them to move him
um
like yeah i mean i i think like to
answer the question dan you have to look
at where their roster is you know and i
i look at their roster and they're in
position to compete for a championship
right now
if desean watson and aaron rodgers and
russell wilson are available
is there any guarantee you get a year
from now and the dynamic's going to have
changed at all you know i think you
almost have to take advantage of that
sort of opportunity especially when you
look at the landscape of college
football
and are you sure that there's going to
be a great one available to you over the
next two years you know i it's just
i think you look at the brown situation
and you got to say to yourself
there's a lot of good there's a lot
there's a lot of good momentum over
coming off the last two years despite
what's happened this year and them not
making the playoffs the franchise is a
good spot the roster's in a good spot
you can compete for a championship right
now
and you know like that's why i think
like they're going to look at it the
same way the rams looked at their
situation last year which is
we need to strike while the iron's hot
let's take a look at what the options
are out there
and the top options look like they're
going to be desean watson russell wilson
and maybe i mean we'll see what happens
aaron rodgers
i wondered about this i think people
speculated when mike tomlin was spawning
all over aaron rodgers earlier this year
yep and people wondered
hey
aaron rodgers pittsburgh mike tomlin
they're going to need a quarterback
there
could you see i i i hate to do this but
you know we have to start landing the
planes here somewhere of where we think
these guys are going to end up but let's
say aaron rodgers leaps green bay
probably going to be in the afc
correct
i would say that be the preference yeah
if you're the packers the preference
would be to ship them out of the
conference okay
uh would denver or pittsburgh
make more sense
for
knowing what they're going to get
i think denver would be i think denver
would be the biggest player for him um
denver is going to have in all
likelihood a higher draft pick
i think denver would be willing to go um
the extra mile to get him denver has
some some players on the team that you
might want
um if you're a green bay
and you know i
i just like denver was on his list last
year too if i can if i remember right
and so like i just think there's a lot
of things about the way denver set that
situation up that are built for a
veteran quarterback to come in and win
and you know it's the receiver group a
young receiver group it's not unlike
what peyton manning walked into right in
2012 with demaryius thomas and eric
decker and and julius thomas at tight
end they've got the same sort of setup
there with jerry judy and kj hamler and
portland sutton and tim patrick um so
you got that do i have to bring though
peyton may be taking over or being part
of ownership in denver
that would be like a plus
for for
for aaron rodgers i would think right is
that a plane do you think
i mean i i think i think peyton manning
is an nfl owner has been in place since
he retired yeah i mean i like everything
i understand i don't know if you've
heard this dan but like
there
there had always been a the assumption
that peyton was going to want to be a
football executive at some point and run
his own show and i and i remember
hearing all the way back when you know
he signed with denver it was actually
sort of a side benefit for him that he
got to see john elway do that job
because john elway's background
obviously has parallels to paint going
into that sort of job right so like
there's that the peyton's always had
that kind of in the back of his head
that maybe he wants to be a football
executive
and then two i've also heard that the
manning families always sort of had an
eye on ownership and that was part of
the reason why over the years peyton
manning never took less on contracts eli
manning never took less on contracts
they always did a lot of endorsements
like i'd always heard that sort of idea
that the manning family was building
capital to maybe someday be able to buy
a team i don't know if they have the
capital to buy a team outright but to be
a part of an ownership group like that
would make some sense and if you were
putting together an ownership group in
denver a group to bid on it in denver
that'd be a pretty powerful guy to have
on your side wouldn't it you know yeah
and you know i know i know peyton really
loves living there that's the other
thing um you know part of the reason why
i think you know he has been a little
slow to
take a job as a football executive
because those opportunities have been
available to him is because he lives a
very comfortable life you know in denver
now and so there are a lot of things
there that sort of line up where it
would make sense you know peyton manning
was part of a group that would bid on
the on the on the broncos talking albert
breer senior nfl reporter for the monday
morning quarterback uh washington
football team is going to have a big
announcement coming up next month uh 2
2-2-22 which we pointed out as
groundhog's day so maybe they don't
change the name they just keep it what
it is but you uh got any thoughts on
this
yeah i mean i i like i think it's
i think what we've seen this year from
that organization i mean it's almost
like
it's almost like comical how like you
know that that it it was illustrated on
sunday with the barrier collapsing and
the fans falling on to jail and hurts
it's like as much work as they've done
over the last two years to try and fix
things there they had a long way to go
and so uh you know between everything
that's happened there
um you know really over the the 22 years
since dan snyder bought the team but you
know
really you know like when you like
between the nickname obviously the
workplace scandal everything that's
happened there over the last couple of
years it's really clear how far they've
had to go
but you know i do think that they've got
some good people in place now
to
change the way we think about that that
organization and you know i think that
this is a big part of it for all of them
so you know the president jason wright's
obviously spearheaded this effort and
you know on the football side ron rivera
and marty herney and martin mayhew i
think have made some progress
um this is a big year for them make no
admit make no mistake about it like you
know they they took a little bit of a
step back this year
in that they're not going to be on the
put in the playoffs
but you know from a quarterback
standpoint from you know just
like like what the staff looks like
standpoint like 2022 is a a big year for
the franchise and you know you'd hope
that
maybe the start of things like people
falling out of the stadium
would stop to end start to end and i do
think that the the rebrand is a big part
of all that
what are the buccaneers doing with
antonio brown what's the uh
the game plan here or strategy
i i think that they're well right now
they're working with the league on how
to handle this um you know i
look like i think we need to we do we
need to look at this for what it is dan
i mean this isn't you know father
flanagan here like this was a football
situation from the start
and that they brought him in in the
first place to
appease their quarterback because tom
brady wanted him there in 2020
he was sort of a bonus piece to the
offense in 2020 the same way gronk was
because those guys had got in late and
it was the coveted year and everything
else those guys had nice contributions
down the stretch brady loves both those
guys brady had the team bring both those
guys back both those guys had a full
offseason both became an integral part
of the offense
um and obviously gronk is it's not fair
in any non-football way to connect gronk
to a b but that was sort of the way
those acquisitions happen and when they
struggled in mid-season this year a big
part of it was because those guys had
become integral parts of what they do
offensively and so when abe's situation
went haywire over the last month um you
know with the fake vaccination card the
lying the suspension everything else
the reason they held on to him was
because he had become an integral part
to what they do from a football
standpoint and he had become too
valuable he'd become valuable enough
where
the
i think the decision makers there have
built up some tolerance for what he was
going to bring off the field where that
tolerance had been zero a year before
and so i think this is that's what this
is it's every single
every single facet of this decision of
of of the antonio brown
um antonio brown's run in tampa
all of it was guided by football and and
right up to the very end where at this
point he's become more of a problem than
he was of value to the team which is
amazing because he was pretty valuable
to the team at the end i don't i don't
think we're being fair to bruce arians
when we say to bruce you know do you was
it a mistake to sign antonio brown he
got a super bowl out of this
i yeah you know they knew that they were
getting somebody they knew what they
were signing up yes but they everybody's
enabled antonio brown
that you know even tom brady's saying we
should show compassion he he's got some
problems well did he have problems
before he took off his clothes
you know in the jets game of course he
did so
it feels like we're going hey you know
he's got problems okay
was anybody addressing these problems
prior to what happened sunday is he
addressing these his agent does anybody
give a damn about him you know that
because he might get another job here
albert but you're gonna have the same
issues
i mean at the end of the day he's like
bruce aaron's a football coach he's not
a psychologist he's not a self-help guy
he's not a goo like he's a football
coach you know what i mean like and
brady wanted him he bruce was probably
handcuffed to say all right tom really
wants him he wanted him a new england
look like and and you know what like new
england did the same things for tom
right like there were josh gordon when
they brought josh gordon in you know i
can tell you for a fact
like the patriots made it clear to to
to tom like okay this is your guy now
like you're gonna you're gonna look out
for him right and so tom has become
used to being in these situations where
it's i want this player on my team i
like this player i need more help
offensively and to facilitate that i'm
going to personally take the guy under
my wing and that's what happened with ab
and i do think like i do think by the
end like tom really did like antonio
like i think that there was a a strong
relationship there but like the idea
that like
the idea that football was going to keep
him in line
it didn't in pittsburgh right like where
like at the end like a team envy not
like a team mvp award going to juju
smith schuster set him off right
and that was a place that had done
everything everything
to facilitate it for him so i i just
i don't know like where
i mean to me like continuing to give him
opportunities
isn't football saving antonio brown it's
reinforcing that he can get out get away
with whatever the hell he wants
and every time he got another chance
whether it was after you know the the
end in pittsburgh whether it was after
the whole bizarre end in oakland with
the with the feet and the helmet and
everything else or the way things ended
in new england with him taking an open
shot at ownership on his way out the
door after threatening people who are
accusing him of some very serious things
continuing to give him opportunities
wasn't football saving him it was
sending him a very clear message dan
like football is going to allow you to
act however the hell you want because
your talent supersedes everything else
that you've done
albert great to talk to you as always we
appreciate your time thank you
all right thanks dan albert breer and
that was well put
you know because until he doesn't have a
job i mean that's when reality sets in
that's when you know okay no nobody
cares no more options here
like i look back on meta world peace
he knew he had a problem and he went and
he he worked on getting better
and i have
total respect for that
i mean he's he's he's interesting he's
quirky he's not dangerous
antonio brown is dangerous
uh albert the lead uh senior or senior
nfl reporter lead strategist for the
monday morning quarterback